hey everyone I've been wanting to make
this video for a while now you all
probably know that album is one of my
favorite writers of all time he left a
huge impact on the crime genre uh
literary critics even considered him
transcending the genre which I think is
a controversial term I'll get into that
later I want to break down some of his
writing methods and things I've learned
from him as a writer and I want to
explore just what makes his book so damn
good for those of you who don't know who
Elmer Leonard is he was a seriously
prolific crime and Western writer born
in 1925. he started out writing westerns
Pulp Fiction pulp short stories and
western novels such as 40 Lashes less
one Valdez is coming and the bounty
hunters his short story 310 to Yuma was
turned into a very successful film that
was then remade if you go back and read
some of his Western stories from that
time they really hold compared to other
Western stories of the time they are
fantastic when the market started going
away from westerns Elmore Leonard
switched into crime fiction I try and
keep my words out of the novel because I
don't wanna I don't want the reader see
me writing to see me using write a word
wow are those some sexy glasses speaking
of glasses you may have noticed I have
some new ones myself they're all thanks
to glassesusa.com one of the biggest
eyewear retailers in the US they offer
thousands of eyeglasses and sunglasses
such as Ray-Ban Gucci Oakley and you
know tons of a lot the glasses started
only 39. so if you like the glasses I'm
wearing in this video what are the
frames I'm about to show you there's a
really good exclusive offer for my
subscribers in the links in the
description down below and when I was
picking out glasses I was a little
insecure about you know which ones I
should get which would fit my face I
actually have a quiz on their website
where you can answer a few questions and
it can give you some suggestions based
on your face size and all of that your
proportions everything it only takes
about a minute to take shopping online
can be fun but it can also be extremely
overwhelming especially with so many
options really love shopping for my new
classes with glassesusa.com they offer
some amazing tools to help you find your
perfect pair one of these tools is the
AR virtual try on I actually use this to
find all of my new frames and it was
super helpful shopping online at glasses
usa.com is a risk-free shopping
experience with free shipping and
returns and 100 money back guarantee
within 14 days glassesusa.com is
offering a super exclusive discount on
top of the coupon discounts that they
already have on the website so again
click on the links in the top of the
description box to get all the details
and once again thank you glassesusa.com
for sponsoring this video all right
let's get back to it one of his early
successes was City primeval A lot of his
novels take place in Detroit swag a lot
of his early 70s books but he also wrote
a lot about Florida one of my favorite
books of his is called maximum Bob what
I think differentiates Elmer Leonard
from other crime fiction writers is his
attention to detail especially with
dialogue when you hear anyone talk about
Elmore Leonard they're talking about his
dialogue La Brava for instance is about
a former secret service agent who is now
taking photographs in Southern Florida
every character comes alive in his books
even even the small ones when you read
his books you can't help but feel like
this was someone he actually met or new
or listen to details are so precise but
so unique it doesn't feel like something
someone could come up with I think
Leonard has gotten his due so to say uh
like in terms of criticism like the
literary Elite kind of uh regard him
very highly he has his own library of
America collection which is usually a
sign that the literary circles have uh
evaluated someone several of his novels
were turned into movies like the book
out of sight which uh star George
Clooney and Jennifer Lopez rum punch was
adapted into Jackie Brown Quentin
Tarantino has spoken a lot about how
inspired he was by Elmore Leonard
Tarantino has even purchased the rights
to 40 Lashes less watches an early novel
or an early Western by uh Elmore Leonard
speaking of 40 Lashes less one one of
the greatest final lines in any book you
should definitely read it so what makes
Elmore Leonard's writing so incredible
first we have to talk about the
characters who really draws from real
life and is not afraid to explore all
facets of of people's existence you know
you'll find so many different types of
characters I mean it it's really a
fantastic variety that he has in his
books you ever heard of the show
Justified yeah that's actually based on
a series of novels and short stories
from Elmore Leonard the first of which
was called Pronto that was actually my
entrance into Elmore Leonard was Pronto
it's like if you took a cowboy from the
1800s and put him into modern day Miami
or modern for that time I guess it was
the 80s or 90s but a lot of his
protagonists are guys like raylen who
are kind of surveying the world from a
bit of a an outdated perspective their
kind of clash with The Changing Times we
always get to see different perspectives
from the good guys and the bad guys
sometimes you don't even know who the
good guys or the bad guys are until
later in the book but you know you see
the typical criminals you see the
typical good guys and each side has
their own sense of humbling idiocy you
know there's a lot of humor in these
books the bad guys almost all the time
are at each other's throats don't really
know how to do the job it's a very
realistic in that sense that the
criminals can be pretty stupid you know
just like the heroes next let's talk
about the pros when you look at the
first chapter of a book like La Brava
it's almost all dialogue and the
dialogue is so specific to each
character it's never hard to follow
who's speaking a lot is implied through
the speakers themselves they had come
out of the hotel the porch lined with
empty metal chairs walked through the
lines of slow-moving traffic to the
beach side of the street where Maurice's
car was parked the Bravo was patient
with the old man but waiting holding the
car door open he hoped this wasn't going
to be a long story they could be walking
along the street the old man always
stopped when he wanted to tell something
important he'd stop in the doorway of
Wolfies on Collins Avenue and people
behind them would have to wait and hear
about bust out joints where he could get
rolled in the old days or how you could
tell a bookie when everybody on the
beach was wearing Resort outfits one of
the best third person limited writers
his perspective he always writes in
third person limited perspective and
he's one of the best writers at it
you'll see a sentence the way he can
bring in point of view into the into the
description is so brilliant you can feel
the character's language through third
person and and that can be really hard
to do especially with third person Omar
Leonard wrote like a ton of books I do
think at a certain point he started
repeating himself especially with
regrets to his protagonists you have the
stoic cowboy-esque guy who is like tough
and can is super cool you know but uh
there is a ton of variety you look at
touch you look at uh kill shot my
favorite Elmore Leonard books probably
40 Lashes less wine impronto what I love
about his westerns and this goes along
with his his later crime work is that
he's really good at exploring the
corruption and the levels of inequality
and brutality especially police
brutality that goes on in the system
very usually about people who live on
the fringes who are outcasts in that
Society people who are people who are
immigrants people who are native
American black people I mean there's so
much Variety in terms of his
protagonists and what he is willing to
look at in the typical genre yes he's
working within the genre elements but
his stories also are atypical of what
you may see especially like the less
good stuff of that era I mean 40 Lashes
less one is an especially great look at
a prison system traditional Western
values racism you know white liberal
approaches to racism it's really a
clever but also very funny funny book
from what I know Elmore Leonard did not
plot his novel so I think the plots are
the weakest quite a few really good ones
that you have to get to the end my
enjoyment now is that you get to see
kind of like the little tangents the
side roads the quirky characters the
pros the dialogue like these are things
that I really enjoy getting into the
book it's kind of how I feel with like
Stephen King you know I don't expect a
great ending from a Stephen King book I
don't expect some I'm there for the ride
I'm there for the experience he talks
about you know he he used to work at an
ad agency I think early on in his career
and get up at like 5 a.m and he'd start
writing and he said he had to write
before he even had coffee because uh the
coffee would be a reward after writing
for a little bit just an incredibly
prolific really fantastic writer even if
you aren't into westerns even if you're
not into crime fiction I do recommend
checking him out so we need my advice
check out Elmore Leonard let me know
what your favorite color Leonard books
are and and yeah I'll talk to you all
later I hope you are having a great day
thank you again to glassesusa.com for
sponsoring the video and thank you for
watching and have a good one bye